bounce ago and breasts - verify and
welcome to some more trouble in
terrorist town we should start a band
I think when it's like in a frenzy just
like that
can we stop with the [ __ ] noise Oh
dudes what you've just murdered me
randomly I catch my booty hoping let's
have a bath together come here it's ja
mm-hmm oh wait where did you go
you guys do you realize this will be
found on mm yeah anyway
oh if I'm a traitor the floor opens up
and I fall into lava you subject so I'm
innocent
are you sure that's striking write this
one down no no no they live always down
here that's what life's fine come here
yeah I'm definitely innocent very good
all right I'm gonna try it and you guys
think oh well is it the green light came
on he's definitely innocent okay either
that's the trick then
it's tomoki's that's a tree eat food he
goes over the door hit you guys over the
door shoots its deadly Birds where you
go where you go thank 9 he's giggling
I'm innocent
Wow I don't want to play your game wait
poodle top sniping okay you check up top
I'm gonna check underneath
yeah this way you get your little tray
[ __ ] hey I just wanted to play with you
guys this cuz I have it I've tried this
doesn't mean we can't play together
[ __ ] you yes I'm innocent this time
around again I really want to be the
evil guy and I fly what are you talking
about I'm testing oh come on dudes
woah woah woah woah so we just threw a
grenade Oh put me near the tester James
Bond skills just scared of my level
right hiding right tower that's me on
the tower
I like nearly killed pewds oh wait who
was it
alright it was spray nope I killed
myself thanks for saving my life you
just not allowed to say okay whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa spoons down max
[Music]
we'll just kill Maxie front of me yeah
yeah every time I guess makes makes you
shoot me oh my god oh my god I can't see
him makes him repulsive died shoot him
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay Tommy the trainer
oh no it's ready you are this focus
we've done he's got [ __ ] gone not
gonna sniper
I've got sniper as well but is he in
there look at this it gives you two
stitches I know please please please
don't kill me okay
oh you're absolutely anyone I'm saying
look you only get two steps to climb on
this huge Tower I was like Derek jump on
my head and go up don't hit me
hey bang what started yeah my house
right behind you why can't I go up here
you can't there's not enough steps to
get away from me anyway I don't want to
be next to you don't matter you're right
Claire yeah max has been really clear
how'd you die what how the [ __ ] are you
supposed to get that what interest boots
and I shot the wrong guy
I'm sorry about that
I'm sorry I didn't mean to hit you with
the barrel syndicate I'm sorry sorry
sorry I killed me hit you the enemy
no I shall kill her but like if you
undead a few turns
I'm in me you may think I'm a barrel but
and you are innocent terrorists trying
to throw it
[Music]
yeah I'm so nice don't worry I got this
yeah dad
all right breasts hope you enjoyed
another episode of trouble in terrorist
town if you want more let me know or
leave a like it helps me out a lot I
really appreciate it for us anyway hit
subscribe to come bro today and I'll see
in the next one
[Music]
Booya